foreign
the queen of a certain kingdom was
Barren though she wished it more than
anything she could not have a child she
kept her sadness hidden in songs and
kindness but the king could discern her
suffering through the smiles for years
she kept her tears to herself her heart
secretly praying for her long desired
child
one day on the Feast of Candlemass a
crow perched in a tree just above her in
the garden startled in her mending the
queen pricked her finger and a drop of
her blood fell onto the pristine snow
she knew at that moment that she would
have a child but her prayers had been
answered she would give birth to the
most beautiful girl in the world with
skin as white as the Virgin Snow with
lips as red as blood and with hair as
black as coal
so hello everyone I'm very excited today
because we are going to present you the
Snow White Project which is coming out
on Kickstarter next week June 6th
um as you know I started working we've
been working on this for several months
with Heather pollinson who's here with
me and so I'm you know we're all both
really nervous because this is like our
little baby that we've been working on
for a long time and uh you know in some
ways we're really doing something that
is both very strange and surprising but
then also something which is a fairy
tale like a fairy tale like everybody
knows about so we what we want to do is
we want to go through
some of the reasons why we're doing this
why we're doing Snow White you know why
we're also doing this series of fairy
tales and why we're doing it now so
first of all Heather thanks for joining
me
you're welcome it's good to be here yeah
and so Heather and I we met uh several
months ago before we did this in White
Project you know she helped me with the
rebranding of the symbolic world as you
know and uh I told her about this
project that I was working on and so for
several years now I've been thinking
about fairy tales I've been thinking
about them very much inside the symbolic
World comparing them to Bible stories
comparing them to myth and realizing to
what extent you know there's just a a
range there's just a scale between Bible
stories myths and fairy tales they're
really of the same nature it's just that
some are more Fantastical you know fairy
tales can be more Whimsical Fantastical
they're able to stretch reality uh much
more but ultimately they just follow
very similar patterns and several people
have had that intuition when you hear
the story of Snow White
you can see there's an apple and then
she eats it and she falls asleep you
know there's a Temptation and there's
all that and and it's as if it's Just
Right Out Of Reach what's this
relationship to the Bible story you know
what's the connection between the story
and the Bible so this is something that
I've been thinking about for uh for a
long time meditating on trying to see
what is going on in the Snow White story
and uh you know I wrote this as a play
for my children a while ago of course
I've added it I changed it but a long
time ago I wrote it as a little play for
my kids as we were homeschooling and uh
as I was you know after we finished
God's dog I was thinking about that
story I just kept coming back in my mind
and I realized you know I think it's
time to retell the fairy tales and this
is in some ways a kind of cultural
moment you know we've been watching for
the past decade people try to
reinterpret the fairy tales change them
adapt them politically to our current
situation make comments on them in some
ways be quite cynical you know if you
think of uh series like the Shrek Series
where they take these uh all these fairy
tale mashups and they make something
very funny very Whimsical but also quite
cynical about what is in this the fairy
tales and there are several versions of
that uh both for adults and for uh
children uh they're you know the uh
Disney had a series called once upon a
time that had like adult versions of the
fairy tales and you can kind of see all
their their kind of uh desires it's more
like a soap opera and so there have been
many efforts to try to kind of dive into
this fairy tale world but to do it in a
way that like I said is it's a bit dark
and a bit cynical and my intuition was
maybe it's time to jump back into the
fairy tales and do something similar
create a kind of world where the fairy
tales cross each other where the
characters uh you know continue on
between the different stories but
ultimately with the purpose of creating
Insight of about what's in those fairy
tales and so the project is for kids you
know you can read the story to your
children you know it's a beautiful
storybook very we're doing it you know
with beautiful materials like a you know
like a 19th century fairy tale storybook
that is well-bound and it looks amazing
uh but the idea is there'll be two
readings in the fairy tale one for the
children one for the adults but now it
won't be dirty jokes and kind of you
know uh references that just go over the
head of the children but rather there's
a layer that is deeper in insight and is
trying to help people see what is really
going on in these fairy tales and so I'm
quite excited and you know this seemed
like an Impossible Project
but I've been very fortunate to be
surrounded by wonderful people and
Heather of course you know has really
just amazed me to what level she's been
able to capture the vision of what it is
that I wanted also everybody knows I
love medieval art I love you know
traditional icons all of that and she
was able to kind of create a visual
language to join
you know more let's say uh 18th 19th
20th century fairy tales early 20th
century fairy tale styles with the the
power of medieval storytelling and so uh
so so Heather you know maybe you can you
can tell us you know first of all I'd
like to know because this is a strange
wild project you're a professional
artist you know you've been doing all
these projects with big with big
franchises Disney and all these
companies and so here's this like icon
cover that actually if you're willing to
help him tell a bunch of fairy tales and
so what is it that made you accept
something like this okay
um well there's a bit of story behind
this and it kind of goes back to around
2017 and I was working on Maleficent two
um in England and it was having a great
time on that film it was a really fun
project we were doing loads of really
opulent kind of brightly colored
medieval stuff and um I had to do tons
of research for that project obviously
designing tapestries carpets things like
that and and what happened was it was
the first time really in my career that
I managed to get the chance to delve
into the medieval world I mean if you
work in the world of film you are always
jump in between different eras you know
like eight months you're on Victorian
and then the next month you're doing
like 16th century Amsterdam or something
so you have to switch very quickly
between all these different languages
and this was the first one that kind of
combined medieval and fairy tale for me
and when I started researching I just
came across this art and it was it
literally just knocked my socks off it
was so interesting and I was like how
did I not know about this before
um so I'm going to show you some of the
art that I encountered and kind of what
it did for me and that sort of gave a
lot of the impetus to this project but
it's something that's been kind of
brewing for a few years and when you
came along it kind of all came together
for me so I'm gonna take you through
um
so when you're working in film
um it's very much like a magpie culture
and we're always looking for things that
are going to kind of best transmit our
story so you're looking around in the
world of design and you're trying to
figure out like what is this artistic
language how can it be used for
storytelling and and ultimately how does
it affect the audience because you know
last time I was on here I was talking
very much about you know what it is to
design for film and very much how we you
know think about emotion and how we can
drive plot you know with different
um different uh languages
and yeah so I started looking across the
sort of Medieval World it was the first
time that I
um encountered iconography and I was
also looking at manuscript arts and I
started to notice there is like very
specific technical things that this art
was doing that was just really
impressing me
so I've just labeled it up here I'll
just go through quickly and very Dynamic
poses and breaking the frame
um simultaneous depiction of multiple
moments in time symbolic use of color
and a manipulation of scale to transmit
meaning
and also using complex perspective
systems that Converge on the viewer and
I was thinking what what is it that
about these features you know what why
is kind of early Christian art developed
in this way
um and I was looking deeper and I was
thinking everything whether it's like 2D
or 3D it's always projecting out and and
it's like it's so powerful and it's like
I see it in churches in England these
are across the bottom you can see their
roof bosses which are um architectural
details that meet in the ribs of Gothic
architecture and but they're some of my
favorite things and they're so creative
um and I think obviously yeah so I was
thinking like why why does IT project
out in the way that it does it's so
Dynamic you know you can see here this
in this Mosaic you know it's like
there's a shadow there because he he
kind of comes out
so I was thinking the only thing I can
think of is because
you know Christianity is all about
receiving in so many ways isn't it it's
all about like receiving the word
receiving communion and I think of
receiving the image it's the same thing
that these are definitely art forms that
are made to be received and and kind of
transmit story to us
so
I just want to make this kind of Point
really obvious there's two depictions
here of
um Emmaus and the one on the left is a
roof boss the one that I absolutely love
and even though you know it's pretty
dilapidated unfortunately these figures
have lost their heads it's like when you
make your way around this roof boss
you're actually experiencing the whole
of this story you've got um Christ here
with the pilgrim bag coming in on the
walk then you've got him at the table
and then you've got him
um you know ascending here as well so
you're like experiencing the whole story
and to me it's like experiencing these
is like similar to experiencing
scripture because when you're reading
scripture you kind of meditate on things
you come back to it it looks different
from different angles so you're sort of
experiencing it in a fresh way every
time and I think
I just want to compare it to this
um painting here which is like the most
famous
um version of Emmaus that we have by
Caravaggio
um and although it's wonderful it's
doing a very different thing it's kind
of it's it's a it's a moment in time
it's it's painted in a realistic way and
this is like the father of like the
Cinematic
um language and also you know the the
snapshot so that it's pulling you into a
different dimension basically whereas
this one to me is kind of affirming
um you you actually reading the story
there so this is the kind of art that I
really love it's kind of it's
Universalist in style it's it's using a
lot of elements to kind of transmit a
massive amount of story in in one in one
piece
um so I was also interested in the sort
of correlation between like art and
scripture and so when you came to with
the project
um I looked at this like the kind of
language that you'd used in the fairy
tale
and um it seemed very interesting
because
it's like we seemed very concise it's
like you considered every single element
of it like everything seemed considered
that there was like the explicit
um elements and also implicit elements
so there's definitely like kind of
layers to it I don't know if you could
talk about that no but it's interesting
that you also the way you said it and I
think this is something which will
surprise people when they read it is my
model for writing the fairy tale is very
much scripture in the sense of the the
scripture has a way of telling a story
which is very concise uh you know and
very simple
without you know stopping on Long
descriptions or describing interstates
like there's none of that in scripture
it's it's quite direct and so I thought
that there was something about that way
of telling the story like the way that
the gospels tell the story you know you
know for uh you know for a 19 for a
Victorian reader is is is quite lacking
but I think there's something about it
which is so simple and powerful and it
comes close to the way that the old
fairy tales were told you know the the
first snow white version is three
thousand words it's very short it's very
concise and there's a sense in which you
can tell it in one sitting and so this
is really what I wanted to recapture in
the way that I that I told the story of
fairy tale so every single sentence was
you know fought over and thought over
and trying to get to the essence of what
it is that's not what it is doing and
there's not a lot of there's not a lot
of Flowery language and a lot of Flowery
descriptions no it must be really hard
because
um like you say it's it's a collective
language isn't it it's done something
that's basically been contributed to is
probably an oral culture
um and it gets changed over time and
kind of distilled like you say that's
very different from a kind of 19th
century novelist who has a kind of you
know particular voice
um but yeah so it's so what was great
about it just this first passage is you
know little things just kind of leap out
in terms of colors and and imagery and
so it was quite clear like you know
where where you wanted to
uh the things that you wanted to
emphasize let's say yeah um so one thing
I did next was
um kind of dived into the world of fairy
tale illustration
um because obviously I was really
influenced by Christian art but we're
not you know we're not on a sacred
subject and so we need to look broader
and and find some kind of synthesis
um so one thing I found that was really
common in fairy tale illustration
um that you talk of is is the silhouette
and I don't know if it's like technical
thing because books are very expensive
to reproduce or you know I don't know
what you think I was wondering if it's
because fairy tales kind of deal with
archetypes and so you know you you kind
of only need a shape to tell you what
that thing is you don't really need the
detail they don't have a particular
identity necessarily these characters
but I think it's also because it's also
to capture probably intuitively but it
it's it's a version of the medieval
storytelling we said we saw before
because in order to create silhouette
art you have to have the character
placed in a manner that everything is
recognizable uh in the movement they're
doing so there's something that's that's
very uh you have to like you see it in
the images here you have to be able to
see them from the side pose or from the
front with the arms moving in a way that
is very clear the action is clear
everything is clear or else or else
you'll just see a big black mass it
doesn't make any sense and so it seems
like a modern way to capture some of
what we see in medieval art which is
this frontal or side poses uh and very
clear clear movement
so
um yeah so having found the silhouette
then I looked into
um what's called the Golden Age
um and what was really interesting is
this this guy here Heinrich Leffler
um he was an Austrian artist and he was
really drawing from the the Byzantine
um style
um in the early 20th century and I found
out a whole load about that movement
that was happening in Austria and in in
The Wider Arts it involved people like
Gustav Klimt and we know that obviously
he was really influenced by the the
mosaics in Ravenna and he brought that
into the Fine Art world but Leffler was
doing that in the the world of
illustration so as soon as I found a
kind of synthesis of of like Christian
art and
um and fairy tale it was like okay well
you know we're clearly on Solid Ground
here because actually this has been done
before
um and it was really nice to discover
his work and Kenny Olsen obviously a
giant of fairy tale illustration really
looked at his stuff Errol McCain he's
much later but kind of was real really
big fan of uh Kay Nielsen and then this
lady Mary Blair was a concept artist at
Disney
and I absolutely love her work she did a
lot of really expressive
um gouache paintings for Disney a lot of
concept work that that made its way into
the films so she seemed like a good
touch Point as well
um and you can see in these influences
already some of what you ended up
putting into the text yeah
at career I've spent
frustration from 1910
um and so I could have done that but I
didn't want to because I wanted to make
sure
um that I wasn't just doing something
like uh you know the the watercolor
artist from the early 20th century
because they've already done it and it's
you know they've already done beautiful
work so it's like okay we need to
blend together some different aspects
and try and bring out you know some have
have a bit of 21st century technology in
there as well so that was really
important
um to find a style that that sort of was
a blend but there was also new
um so speaking of Disney obviously as
part of the project you've got to look
back at all the incarnations of Snow
White and we looked at a lot of
illustration together didn't we but what
kind of popped out was obviously the
1937 Snow White and the Seven Dwarves
film you know it's the most iconic
um adaptation everyone knows it it's
amazing
um but what was interesting was just
looking around the um the production of
that that film and what I found was that
in 1933 there was another Snow White by
uh the Fleischer brothers and the story
is that they were the kind of East Coast
um rival to Disney in the in the 20s and
30s
and um their stuff is absolutely amazing
by the way if you go on YouTube you can
see their cartoons
um they're so inventive but they're very
very dark and their version of Snow
White which you see on the left is
absolutely mad go and look at it so it's
got all like it's got the elements there
there's Betty Boo for Snow White there's
the queen and then there's some very
strange creatures
um and what I realized is that when Walt
Disney made his Snow White in 1937 it
wasn't like it wasn't coming into
um a culture of like Snow White being
wholesome it was he actually consciously
decided to do a kind of radical
traditional version of Snow White with
new technology
um and so yeah it seemed interesting to
me because you've talked about you know
what's going on at the moment in culture
and the way the fairy tales are being
depicted
um and you know it seems like a similar
moment that you know you could actually
um do something traditional and it could
it could um you know become interesting
in that environment so yeah yeah I think
that when you presented me this this is
this image of Fleischer and Disney I
think it was really it just hit me that
that's exactly what it is we're trying
to do and in some ways that's exactly
the moment that we're in which is the
surprising moment when things have been
so twisted and become so surreal and
strange that they're almost
unrecognizable so like you said the
Betty Boop the Snow White uh the
Fletcher Snow White it's really
fascinating and hypnotizing and and
interesting but it's almost
unrecognizable as the story of Snow
White you really need to know the story
deeply in order to realize that this is
Snow White because it's all irony and
comment and kind of joking about certain
yeah in the story
um and so it's this is a in some ways
we're in the exact same position where
exactly and when when you watch the
Disney Snow White I think everyone looks
at it and goes oh it's from you know
it's old it's from the past yeah it's
like the truth it's just this tradition
that has been around it's just like no
he knew what he was doing I mean just
look at everything about it look at the
titles you know he was Reviving medieval
forms in in the late 30s you know for a
reason so that that was really
interesting
um anyway so I got yeah I do loads and
loads of research
um I had tons and tons of stuff to look
at and this is just a kind of picture of
my process on the left is me in
Thessaloniki and I went to an exhibition
on uh Ravenna mosaics and that um people
will know is quite famous pattern that
made its way into the book as a kind of
snowflake design
so I'm basically collecting patterns and
Designs all the time and then obviously
on the right is like what you see behind
me
um so what I'll do is
um because I've got all these elements
I'll just bring them all together on a
pin board and basically like after I've
lived with it for a few months it tends
to kind of synthesize in my mind and
helps me make decisions as I'm drawing
okay so this is the cover of um our book
and just wanted to talk about it in
terms of
ornamentation now ornament gets quite a
bad rep it's like always at the bottom
of the of the kind of Visual Arts
hierarchy but I have a love for ornament
because I want to work with it a lot in
film
um and it can do quite a bit you know
um so you can see that I've done a kind
of decorative panel but I've drawn from
um mainly mosaics but Byzantine ornament
that I've drawn mainly from the more
florid aspects you know because I felt
like they would fit into you know the
idea of fairy tales so getting kind of
flowers and Vines and things like that
and then
um you see this pattern here that goes
around
um and I picked that because obviously
you've made the kind of reference to
Genesis and you know I've got the tree
but you don't really want to show the
snake so I just thought why don't we
just have like a serpentine
pattern you know it's like it's not so
obvious but hopefully it's just enough
um so that was the thinking behind that
and then obviously the with sitting
within the ornament there's lots of
details of the story
um so yeah that's our cover
and this is also one of the things that
was important to to both of us was you
know when you think of fairy tale world
you really see uh Neil Gothic is the way
that people tend to go immediately like
the way that people understand the
Medieval World
um there's there's certain tropes which
if you if you if you don't think about
it too much and you go simply at it you
end up with kind of new Gothic or or at
least late late Romanesque uh imagery
and one of the things we wanted was to
incorporate some Byzantine aspect on the
one hand to connect with that medieval
imagery but also to be able to have a
bit of Wonder and surprise in the image
yeah yeah
okay so this is one of the illustrations
and it's it's it's good that you said
that Jonathan because
um
in in conceptualizing the style of it I
really didn't want it to be a certain
moment in time in a certain place
um for the reasons that I talked about
before I I much prefer art that is kind
of Universalist and
um I think my aim was it should feel
like more like a kind of Christian dream
world than you know oh that's a 14th
century you know wherever
um again I've spent a lot of my career
doing very specific historical pieces
um and I actually find it's much more
enjoyable to draw from different sources
and and pull them together but I mean
people will notice yeah there's there's
Byzantine there's also Romanesque
um this one
um I feel like was more you than me
because you gave really specific
description for this illustration I
basically just had to draw it and you
design the king and the queen I think
um so I don't know if you want to talk
about it well I think that the first
thing to say is that what you said about
a Christian dream world that is exactly
what we're going for and it's not
something that we're going for just in
this project but it's something that I
was kind of going for already in God's
dog right it's the idea that we've had
this interesting moment in history where
Tolkien who is of a devout Christian
created a fantasy world or you know
developed a fantasy Trope in a way that
was based on pre-christian and Pagan and
uh you know folk elements uh and so what
we're trying to do is in some way push
that in in a direction that will
surprise everyone which is to have a
fantasy world but that is based really
on on Christian tropes and on Christian
imagery on Christian and you see that
it's already there right in the fairy
tale world it's already there very
implicitly you know if you think of
Disney's Sleeping Beauty for example
like that's a Gothic you know math it
really does take in some of the medieval
and Gothic imagery but we wanted to do
it in a way that's far more expensive
explicit and so we're bringing in tropes
of Christian iconography uh not
explicitly but you know the way the
story is told the way that that the
layout is done and so here of course we
have an image which is
um you know basically the image of
Constantine and Helen right that's that
are standing together but that that is
also joined with a kind of Adam and Eve
uh image with the tree in the center and
so really bringing in different images
from the Christian tradition but uh
telling the bring bring them in a way
that most people won't know like if
someone looks at this they'll just
they'll just see it they won't
necessarily understand what we're
dragging into it but that is what that's
what we're bringing into the image yeah
yeah and I think you know for me the
Byzantine world is pretty new
um and I was really interested to study
it but naturally because I live in
England and I'm surrounded by kind of
Western medieval art it's inevitable
that that's going to come in and so I
kind of welcome that synthesis and the
other thing to say is you know in the in
the medieval English churches that they
were they were like um absorbing the
Byzantine style and the Roman s style
anyway and kind of appropriating it so
all of this stuff is really linked
together yeah so yeah as you said
there's the by kind of yeah Helen I mean
it's pretty clear right yeah it's very
clear
um this is the first Ivory we've looked
at actually and I haven't talked about
them yet but
um I know that you're a big fan and it
was a really big part of my thinking on
this um job because
um I just I love the way they're
stylized and I
I found them not particularly this one
but there's quite a few I've looked at
that are like these little like
theatrical vignettes you know you often
get these like frames with a curtain and
then there's like you know one of the
evangelists inside you know writing the
gospels
um yeah with architectural uh framed
office yes
exactly exactly that so
um and I know that this whole project as
you said was conceived initially as a
theatrical project so again it seemed
like a good language to go to
um so yeah so this is
um Constantine and Helen
uh you know I looked at lots of kind of
manuscripts with with the city and just
turn it into a decorative frame again
that's a nice kind of economy there
um and then these if you look at these
patterns here
it's obviously had to design wanted to
do a pattern for the key and the queen
that had some coherence in the frame but
they've got different
um motifs in the king's one I found on a
Byzantine robe and it had this it had
this weird um thing going through the
middle going in two directions and I
don't know about you but there is a
subtle thing in your um in your text
where the king's kind of dubious and I
was like yeah that's that's the right
symbol for him you know it kind of
varies too quickly and all of that and
then and then with the queen you know
this is quite a typical
um brazanti design with the two birds
but you know they're looking they're
looking
um away from each other so it just gives
that unsettling feeling in the marriage
I think
um and again like all of this is
historically accurate but I've selected
it for story reasons
um
so
that's the Rogues yeah so both of these
on the left you've got the death of the
queen
um and on the right is
um the death of Snow White and they
again you gave me a direction for this
so it was the icon of the Door Mission
and so you can see there's a mirroring
between the two
um pieces
um and again the reference with the
ivory yeah yeah and so this is I mean
this is an example where
you know we're trying to pull in imagery
from the Christian tradition without you
know without being explicit people most
people will look at this and never know
what what we're pulling from but there's
a strength in the composition right in
some ways what we're doing is we're
using all this powerful storytelling
language that has that just was
developed organically over centuries
within the church and and you know why
why couldn't we use it why shouldn't we
use it and so the powerful image of of
the woman of the feminine you know uh as
this as this uh horizontal line in the
image with the with the man kind of
standing over being a vertical in
vertical relationship to to the woman
it's a it's a very simple powerful uh
tool for for helping to kind of
intuitively understand the relationship
of the max into the feminine you know uh
I mean it's very simple so yeah so it's
but and when you look at it it's very
effective you know both of those images
are very effective and in terms of what
they're doing yeah so the nice thing
about this you've got the angle of his
crown going down to the dead Queen and
then that goes down there and then your
eye ends up on Snow White who's the you
know
potential future I think
um but I think yeah while we've got
these two up I just want to mention if
you see the way that we're using
Silhouettes so
like I said in your text there was there
was explicit action and then implicit
action so
um here you've obviously got the queen
and the
um the king you know rendered in full
color the
um
the Midwife is kind of half silhouette
and then you've got the Widow Queen
who's basically obviously she's not
there right at that scene but she's kind
of looming in the background because
she's about to come on the stage yeah
you know she she's just she's just a
shape at the moment so yeah I wanted to
reflect kind of the hierarchy in your
writing with the kind of visual
hierarchy in the illustrations and then
you see with this one you've got the
prince kneeling and that's because he's
he's kind of submitting to her isn't he
so we don't need to see the details of
the prince at this point and all of the
kind of um visual emphasis is on Snow
White yeah and it's important to
understand for people that you know
while we worked quite so much on this
this whole story because much of the
there's a large well large there's a
part of the narrative which is not in
the text so there's a there's a there
are little strains of narrative which
appear only in the images and and so
people have to pay attention to the
images as they're reading to get subtext
and to get some of the things that that
is that are that is happening that isn't
mentioned in the so for example the fact
of the Widow Queen already there in the
background as you know the the Queen the
mother of Snow White is exiting the
story that's a little hint of that but
there are a few more of those as the
story progresses yeah
so this is the Widow Queen now I'm on
the left you can see uh I think early
20th century illustration it's one of
the many ones that I looked at but this
one really stood out to me because she's
it says at the bottom mirror mirror in
my hand who's the fairest of the land
and I was like okay that's different to
what we're all used to right you know
because we all know the mirror mirror on
the wall That's the famous one and
Heather literally had me change the way
that I wrote it because she had such a
great idea about this when I saw the
image also of the queen holding the
mirror in her hand I thought this is
amazing she's holding a cell phone like
she's literally taking a selfie and uh
and I realized that that this for now at
least this was really the most powerful
way to present the the story so so it
was it was a great change yeah so that's
right so it was like this really at
first it was like there's really
something about this that I need to pay
attention to and then eventually I
realized
and I was like okay so we're living in
the age of narcissism clearly and you
know we're all captivated by these
devices and I know a lot of people have
made
um comparisons between phones and
mirrors I think Paul kingsnorth was
talking about it recently
um and I started to think about it I was
like yeah so
um let's think about kind of the whole
social media thing and how is that how
is that like a kind of feedback loop
um and I you know I'm on Instagram and
you know now and again I put up a design
or picture that I've done or something
basically what you're doing is you're
kind of looking for you know oh did
anyone like my picture let's have a look
you know it's like a little bit of
affirmation right so yeah you're asking
in the mirror who's the fairest yeah
okay and and what Instagram does which
is really dark is it um when you first
join it shows you a lot of the things
that you want to see But as time goes on
it starts pushing more and more ads at
you right so it starts to become
undermining and um you know these days
if I go on I just get told you know that
I'm kind of old and wrinkly and all of
that stuff because like they know I'm
45. and so it's actually an awful thing
if you pick up the the mirror and you
just you know so
so I was thinking that's an interesting
relationship so you're basically looking
for something and you get the opposite
um and then I started thinking about a
bit more and I think we all know
stories of people who kind of got So
Into You know their Tick Tock accounts
or Instagram that they've actually
started to you know have surgeries and
stuff and they end up kind of destroying
themselves you know because they become
so captivated with The Narrative of of
the mirror right so this is what happens
to the queen she starts to believe the
mirror of more than you know say her
husband you know the king clearly loves
her but again the danger we have in the
modern world is we're not seeking
affirmation from our families we're
actually seeking affirmation in the
algorithms and so there's this very
dangerous kind of thing that can happen
that can destroy you and I thought okay
so that's maybe this is one of the
reasons we're making Snow White now
because these themes are so kind of
present and in our version I really did
try to push that you know it's so weird
that I I had that intention in this
story to to bring about something like
that but I didn't think of the mirror in
the hand when you showed it to me was
like yeah that's exactly what I'm doing
and and so the idea is that uh the queen
you know ultimately ends up destroying
herself herself she ended up just she
ended up destroying herself through this
Obsession that she has uh with finding
out who's the most beautiful and so that
image of the person you know looking in
their phone or obviously it's not just
that but that's a good example of what's
going on looking in their phone and then
becoming obsessed with the tropes of
beauty like you said to the point where
they will destroy their faces destroy
their body or become caricatures of
humans sometimes it's not just it's like
even these makeup all these like makeup
tutorials where you know people you can
see like they're just caking it on in a
way that looks good on the phone but you
can tell even looking at the in the
photo that if I saw this person in real
life I would run away from them like
with all their like really strong lines
on the nose and all that it's like it's
it's this living for the mirror like yes
it's it's wild it's like transforming
yourself for the way that the the the
phone takes a picture of you
yeah yeah yeah because you're so
captured by the mirror and then that's
what these images show that she's you
know we never really see her interacting
with humans we only see her staring into
you know but she's she's staring into
the mirror or staring eventually at the
Apple which becomes the kind of
um you know the end of things yeah so
yeah that that was a that was a really
fun thing to to kind of weave through it
um
these are a couple that kind of look
look
um nicely together and the one on the
left is the death of the king and the
reason I'm showing this is
um because there's been a lot of chat
recently about you know fatherlessness
and and so I really wanted this one like
it's framed by the death of the king
um and in the middle is Snow White
looking so vulnerable
um and she's obviously playing with with
a ball that is the same as the fruit on
the tree and so and then up above we can
see the queen with the hunter so again
they're in silhouette
um so so but yeah it's what it's one of
my favorites actually
um
and on the one on the right is a prince
and I gotta admit that was my little
Indulgence I just wanted to draw a
princess of course I think you kind of
let me get away with that it wasn't
really kind of that part of the story
it's like this is the portrait of the
print it's perfect right even though in
the story we don't talk about it that
way but it's like like I said you know
if you you're going to represent the
prince and you want him to have presents
and and a kind of Regal quality you know
having him on the horse is the best way
to do it so it was a perfect choice yeah
you let me have that one yeah and I was
very happy with that
Okay so
so then
double page spread at the palace so this
is a nice example of you know lots of
things going on
um you know multiple
um activities going on in one in one
frame and we see the prince meeting Snow
White
um by the time he leaves he's in
silhouette against the rosy Dawn
um I think the the main thing to say
about this one is it's really really
influenced by the the ivories yeah and
you know the first drawing I did was was
literally just in in Ivory a line
drawing and um and this is it kind of
colored up but yeah I think it was the
first one I did as well wasn't it I
think it was I think it was because it
was also very complex and we wanted to
do a lot in the image yeah and sometimes
it's the one that looks the most like uh
uh almost like a medieval illumination
you know because of how how it's split
into with the colors and you know it's a
flat architectural Motif with yeah
characters inside the windows very
theatrical as well I mean it's like I
think of it as a stage set this one yeah
yeah that's one of the ones also that
I'd kind of worked hard on I did designs
of it myself with with someone else
trying to kind of figure out how to do
it in a way that makes sense
yeah yeah inherited quite a lot from me
on that one but the um you know like the
Gargoyles and the angel and everything
it's really nice details
um next one showing is them it's the
Woodland scene
um so all of the Alice illustrations are
quite formalized
um and I knew that once we got into the
woods it had to get a bit Wilder
um the the reference on the top is was
my main touch point for the for the
woods because I just knew like as soon
as I read it I was like the
the trees are going to make our frame
so this is a like first sketch that I
did
um and then this is it colored up but it
was such a good idea to move from
architectural Framing and then keep the
framing aspect but use trees to do it
it's a very simple intuitive change but
it it really marks the transition
between uh like Into the Wilderness and
into the the Wilds of the Woods yeah so
we can see the hunter there and there is
very much a you know a sense of that
kind of downward path that she was going
that she's going down into the dwarf's
house and then
um in the text it says a quirky house
stood there as strangely charred like
house
so um yeah I really wanted to make it
look you know tiny and strange and
um obviously yeah like you can see
there's a silhouettes of animals
um the hunter I really like the
character of the hunter yeah pretty face
looking isn't he yeah yeah
um
but yeah anyway going on
yeah so this is um
uh Snow White in the cottage and she's
eating at the doors table and with the I
mean this one I just kind of just saw it
in my head I didn't really know like
formally whether it was going to work
but it was definitely influenced by
seeing those roof bosses with the kind
of you know you've got like two
perspectives I was I drew her and then I
was just like I'm just gonna flatten out
that table because it's I know that you
said to me uh the whole scene in the
dwarves Cottages was all about
um pointless repetition or
Cycles yeah
it's as if she's you know the idea is
that Snow White you know part of the
part of what Snow White is is of course
the transition of a young girl into
Womanhood and one of the things that it
seems to show is that when Snow White
you know makes that transition she falls
into a space where she's in contact with
all these uh you could say
uh let's say unacceptable Mates is the
good way to understand it so she's
dealing with like all these quirky
idiosyncratic old men basically or that
don't that can't be her her husband they
can't be you know her
they can't join with her and so and then
she learns to clean and cook and stuff
and so she has all the negative aspects
of what it is to be a woman let's say a
tradition traditionally so she she's
with all these you know like these old
men that don't that that are like quirky
aspects of what masculine is and then
she's cleaning and cooking and so she
needs to find her prince like she needs
to find the reason why she's going
through this transition in the first
place and you can understand that also
just in general like a woman's body
changing and at first having to deal
with this cycle and like what is this
thing like what is this painful annoying
thing that I have to deal with all the
time what's the reason for it uh and
then ultimately realizing in marriage
and in and in child and in having
children that that oh that's the reason
like this is in some ways what this is
for so that's what we wanted to suggest
in that part of the story
yeah
so I definitely want
ing lots of circular motifs and also all
the um illustrations in the dwarves
Cottage feel much more kind of
psychological to me for some reason you
know like there's a there's a
transformation happening and it's much
it's much less um figurative and
naturalistic
um so this is the illustration of the
dwarf's house
um and again it was you know it's like a
doll's house basically I've always loved
illustrations of houses where the
front's taken off and you can see in all
the little rooms
um so again there's a lot of circling
motifs and um there's the drawers I
didn't really I emphasized the
idiosyncrasies of the dwarves that
they're kind of like a a unit if you
know what I mean that seemed right for
some reason because we were having such
emphasis on her
um
and so yeah I think it's I think it's
perfect and then you kind of see them
going up there with their their clubs
and their knives yeah that's great yeah
yeah
um and here's a couple of illustrations
from the end
um so here's the witch we've we've
already seen with the apple and then
um Snow White after she's eaten the
Apple
um
you know in very simple choices that are
that are intuitively right to have the
you know the architecture now grown over
with thorns and uh you know obviously
the crack mirror and all of these images
and having also the you know the the in
the the beginning when Snow White enters
into the dwarves house you have all
these cobwebs and there's like this
unsettled aspect of what she's going
through and what she it's like things
haven't settled yet she hasn't found the
reason and so the cobwebs appear at the
at the dinner table and then they appear
again here in the in this kind of moment
where the witch is losing control I
could say we could say or kind of
devolving into into uh kind of obsessive
Madness
yeah yeah
um that's it actually because I've I
think we need to leave some well of
course we can't show all these can't
show all of them
um but yeah there is a lot of things
hidden in the illustrations and I really
hope um people will be interested to buy
it and and find more
um this is uh just to show this is gonna
be the frontis piece this is like a
drawing I'm doing at the moment it's
kind of work in progress
um that'll be at the front of the book
yeah and
um this is yeah this is our Kickstarter
campaign basically a couple of images
from there
we're gonna have so the idea is we're
really going to so we're trying the way
we're doing the kickstarter was really
first of all to try to make it uh
accessible to everyone who would like to
get it so you know the the first prices
are quite reasonable but then we realize
like we're really we're doing it making
a treasure here like we're really making
something that is quite unusual at this
time to make something so celebrate
celebratory so ornamental like
unapologetically you know uh diving into
all these patterns and stuff so we
thought we need also to give people the
opportunity to really jump in and go
crazy and so the you know the highest
tiers have a leather bound book with
like uh with actual little jewels on the
corners and and we're having I'm also
doing a very complex illustration of the
scene where Snow White uh receives the
Apple from the queen
um you know and I'm doing all these
details very similar of course to the
way that Heather did it because that's
also my
go to right is to think in medieval
style to have everything compressed into
an image so I'm also making one uh and
we're doing all kinds of stuff we're
having we're gonna have pins and and
it's gonna be it's gonna be really uh
for people who are interested in it like
they can really jump in and and have a
lot of fun with this Kickstarter so
we're we're definitely I think you'll
see how excited we are about this
project when you see you know everything
that we're putting into this Kickstarter
so this is really the beginning to be
honest this is the first book we're
going to do eight books in all
um that are going to take the same
approach to storytelling but as you
notice when as the stories continue
they'll they will accumulate references
and they'll be crossover of characters
and you'll see the fairy tale World kind
of come alive and start to make sense
more and more to you the uh I've already
written four of the fairy tales I still
have a few to write and Heather has
agreed to work as artistic director on
the whole series and so we're gonna have
a through line it's going to be coherent
and and uh visually powerful
um and we have great illustrators in
line to do this so it's going to be
really wonderful where I this is
honestly the mo the thing that excites
me the most about my work at this time
is is this fairy tale series and also
starting the symbolic World Press so
that we can do this and we can continue
to do this so uh and so yeah so Heather
thanks for for taking being such a in
some ways it's a big risk for you to do
something like this and so we definitely
appreciate the the amount of time and
energy you put into this oh it's been
brilliant I've really loved it and um
yeah I hope yeah I can't wait to see it
printed
so everybody go to the kickstarter page
you'll see the link in the description
um this might not be we might not have
started yet if not you can sign up to to
to get uh reminders when we're starting
and if we've already started the
kickstarter then please back it you know
and share it to your friends and
everything because we this is a we think
it's a watershed moment it's time to to
re-celebrate our stories it's time to do
it unapologetically and and in a way
also that is going to bring more insight
to what these stories are about not just
naively you know not just innocently but
to take some of the knowledge that has
been uh Unearthed in the postmodern
tropes uh but then apply it to a higher
good so thanks everybody for uh paying
attention to us I hope you're as excited
as we are and we'll talk to you very
soon
thank you